[موسيقى]
لليوم الرابع على التوالي تسابق فرق
الانقاذ الزمن والطقس السيء ايضا بحثا عن
ناجينا لا يزال عالقين تحت الانقاض كارثه
انسانيه جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا
وامتدت اثاره الى سوريا الاف المباني
تحطمت فوق رؤوس ساكنها لتخلف ماساه تزداد
كلما مر الوقت حيث تتضائل معها فرص انقاذ
مزيد من الارواح التغطيه على العربيه
مستمره من استوديوهات دبي انا عزام احييكم
وهذه الخامسه
[تصفيق]
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين قفز التحصيل الضحايا هذا
الزلزال لاكثر من ثمانيه عشر الف قتيل في
الوقت الذي يعمل فيه حتى الان رجال
الانقاذ في سباق مع الزمن الانتشار
لناجينا محتملين محاصرين تحت انقاذ الاف
المباني التي انهارت بفعل الزلزال ففي
تركيا اعلنت السلطات ان عدد وفيات الزلزال
ارتفعا الى
16,170 قتيل فيما ذكر المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان حصيله ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
ارتفعت الى
356 قتيل
من جانبه اكد المبعوث الاممي الخاص لسوريا
جير بيدرسون على ضروره ايصال المساعدات
للمناطق المنكوبه طبعا باسرع الطرق ايضا
وبشكل فعال
ضرب شمال غربي سوريا حيث كانت الازمه
الانسانيه تتفاقم بالاصل التقارير
الانسانيه تشير الى الحاجه الطارئه
للمساعدات اللوجستيه وفرق الانقاذ
والملاجئ نحتاج الى المساعده بشكل ملح في
اي مكان بغض النظر عن الحدود بشكل طارئ
وفوري وعبر اسرع الطرق واكثرها فعاليه
المزيد ينضم الينا من القامش لمراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش جمعه اهلا بك الجديد
وحجم المساعده المطلوبه الان في هذا الوقت
ميسون يعني الارقام تتحدث لكن المساعدات
لا تصل المعاناه تتعمق مع كل دقيقه وكل
ساعه تمضي على
عشرات بالمئات السوريين على قنا تحت
الانقاذ في سلقين وفي الاتارب وفي
اللاذقيه وفي جبله وفي جنديرس تحديدا يعني
حتى الان المساعدات التي كانوا يتوقع ان
تدخل منتصف هذا النهار من معبر باب
السلامه
تاخرت لا يمكن معرفه الاسباب لماذا تاخرت
هذه المساعدات بالدخول سواء كانت الامميه
او حتى الدوليه بينما بينما المنافذ
الجويه مطار دمشق مطار حلب مطار اللاذقيه
تتوافد عليها الطائرات التي تحمل مساعدات
من دوله الامارات من الجزائر من الصين من
ايران من سلطنه عمان من الاردن من مصر هذه
هي المساعدات يعني تستقب الرئاسه السوريه
وايضا الهلال الاحمر وتتجه الى المدن
والبلدات المنكوبه في اللاذقيه حماه جبله
طرطوس والجزء الواقع تحت سيطره النظام اي
مركز مدينه حلب ولا تجد اي منافذ للدخول
الى مناطق سيطره المعارضه التي تبقى حتى
هذه اللحظه بدون تسجيل اي مساعدات تاتيها
من الخارج الجمعه كان في حديث انه كان في
شاحنات عالقه قبل الزلزال وقد دخلت الان
ولكنها كانت مقرره لمساعده
المحتاجين بصوره عامه في ظل الوضع
الماساوي في سوريا ولكن طبعا الان نحتاج
الى مساعدات من نوع اخر يبدو حتى الان
انها لم تصل من الحدود او حتى من الجانب
الاخر من سيطره منطقه او منطقه سيطره
النظام جمعه دعنا نتحدث الان على موضوع
اخر يتعلق بعمليات الانقاذ واستمراري حتى
هذه اللحظه
يعني لسوء الحظ حتى هذه اللحظه ونحن نتابع
بشكل
مستمر مع فريق الدفاع المدني في المناطق
التي يبحث فيه اعضاءه عنا جين اليوم لم
تصلنا اي ارقام للناجين يعني لم يتم
العثور على اي ناجين تحت الحطام سواء في
بلده الاتارب او جنديررس او سلقين
ايضا لانه الارقام الان بصوره عامه يقال
بدانا النشره نتحدث عن 18 قتيل او اكثر
قليلا ولكن الان الحديث يشير الى مقتل
حوالي العشرين الف قتيل ان كان في سوريا
وتركيا معا بسبب الزلزال
نعم يتم العثور على الجثث يعني مصادر
الرسميه سواء في يعني جبله او اللاذقيه او
حلب اعلنت عن انتشال اكثر من 15 جزء اليوم
المصادر رسميه في مناطق المعارضه انت اكثر
من
جثث اليوم تطبعنا العدد يرتفع ايضا ميسون
لان عدد كبير من المصابين المتواجدين في
المشافي ايضا يغادر الحياه نتيجه الجروح
والاصابات وهناك ايضا اناس لم يتم تنزيلهم
في سجلات المتوفيين يتم الان تسجيلهم عند
وصولهم الى سواء الى المساجد او الى
المقابر يتم تسجيلهما بالتالي العدد يسمح
لي جمعه
لما هو معلن حتى الان في ارقام غير معلنه
ولم يصلوا اليها وهذه صور الان حصريه
وصلتنا تظهر حجم الدمار في ادلب نشاهد
مناطق كامله س بالارض مبانيها طبعا نشاهد
عمليات الانقاذ لا زالت مستمره في بعض
بقع في تلك المنطقه ولكن الدمار هائل جدا
ونحن نتحدث عن ارقام فيما يتعلق بمن قتلوا
في الجانب السوري والتركي قد وصل الى
20,000 طبعا تحت هذه المباني التي دمرت
كليا على الارض لا نعلم ان كان هناك لازال
عائلات دفنت بحالها او لا طبعا مع الايام
سيتضح ذلك ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه وكما نشاهد
من خلال عمليات الانقاذ لازال هناك امل
لدى رجال الانقاذ بان يكون هناك من هم على
قيد الحياه تحت الارض اعود لك جماعه تفضل
خلال يعني ساعات النهار المبكره كان هناك
لا يزال اصوات على الاقل من بعض البنايات
مثلا في بلده جنسيه جنديرس توجه اليها فرق
الانقاذ المدني لكن هذه الاصوات خفتت مع
الوقت ويبدو ان يعني مرور ثلاثه ايام
بلياليها يعني يقلص فرص العثور على
ناجين رغم انه يعني اهالي اهالي المفقودين
تحت هذه الانقاب لا يزال يتسلحون بالامل
حتى يعني البعض يقول لنا بانه حتى لو تم
يعني انتشالهم اموات المهم ان يعني تتوقف
هذه المعاناه معاناه الانتظار ويعني
انتظار حتى سماع اي خبر عنهم باي حاله كان
ولكن عموما يعني ارقام الناجين والعثور
على
الخاصه في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا كما قلت
هناك يعني ثلاث حالات في مناطق
اللاذقيه وحلب كبير يعني من خلال النظام
الصور التي نشاهدها يعني ليس من السهل
تحتاج ربما الى اسابيع او اكثر لنقلها
والبحث عن من هم تحت هذه الانقاض تركيا
كانت تحدثت على لسان
مسؤول هناك بانه ارتدادات الزلزال لا
تزالت
قائمه حتى الان يشعر بها بين الفتره
والاخرى ماذا عن سوريا
يعني سوريا يعني يعني اثر الزلزال او
ارتدادات وتصل يعني بشكل طفيف الى سوريا
لكن احد هذه الارتدادات اليوم تسبب بسقوط
مبنى متداعي ايضا في جنديرس ليله امس كان
هناك يعني هزه ارضيه على الحدود السوريه
التركيه ادى الى سقوط مبنى في
بلده يعني مدينه حرستا التابعه لدمشق فرق
الانقاذ صباحا اكتشفت جثه لرجل مسن في تحت
هذا المبنى وكانت تبحث عن رجل اخر يعني
المخاوف من حدوث الارتدادات لا تزال
موجوده وان كانت تصلوا بشده اقل الى الى
داخل الاراضي
السوريه لكن يعني يبقى التركيز الاكبر على
يعني البحث عن الرجيم متوقعين تحت الانقاض
وتحديدا في سلقين وفي جنديرس التي لا تزال
يعني حوالي 50 مبنى مدمر لم يشملها جهود
البحث ولا حتى الانقاذ لذلك يتوقع ان يكون
تحت الخمسين مبنى مئات من الاشخاص الذين
تنقدوا حياتهم وبدرجه اقل من بقى على قيد
الحياه وهذا عدا المخاوف من المباني
المتصدعه نشاهد الصور طبعا من ادلب هذه
الصور الحصريه الان لعمليات الانقاذ وايضا
للمباني منها المهدوم جزء منها من
هالمتصدعه وكله تحت الخطر على كل ابقى
معنا جمعه نذهب لمشاهد
وصور لعمليات الانقاذ في سوريا ونعود اليك
مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
الجديده
[تصفيق]
يلا براءه
يلا يلا
يلا
تعال تعال
[موسيقى]
واعود الى مراسل العربيه من القامشلي جمعه
عكاش لنتحدث عن الوضع على الارض وفي ظل
غياب المساعدات وايضا في الظل ما ذكرت قبل
قليل والمتعلق بالاصابات وغياب الدعم كيف
يتصرف الناس في الشارع وبالمقابل الحاله
النفسيه هل لك ان تصفها لنا ما الذي يدعم
هؤلاء في التحرك على الارض الان
يعني ميسون المحرك الاساسي هو الامل الامل
بالعثور على ناجين تحت هذه الامطار وان
كانت يعني يعني حيز هذا الامل يضيق مع
مرور الدقائق وليس الساعات لان فرص العثور
على ناجين بعد اربعه ايام
بدون اكل وشرب اكيد مصابين تصبح يعني شبه
معدومه ايضا يعني معظم فرق الانقاذ لديهم
يعني هم من سكان المكان لديهم يعني اشخاص
معلقين تحت هذه الامطار
طبعا بالضبط مثلا من الفريق الدفاع المدني
فقدوا حياتهم في هذا في هذا الزلزال تحت
الانقاض وهم جميعا من ابناء المنطقه
فبالتالي يعني هم يبحثون عن اهل واقارب
ايضا اضافه ان هناك يعني يعني الشعور
بالغزلان نوعا ما من قبل يعني الاهالي
وفريق الدفاع لان المساعدات وصلت يعني كنت
اتحدث يعني مع زميلي محمود على الحدث
احدهم ارسل لي رساله وقال يعني التمينك ان
تقول هذه الرساله على الهواء
مضمون هذه الرساله ماذا ستفيدنا مساعداتكم
لوصلت متاخره في قبورنا بمعنى الناس تقول
المساعدات الوصله المتاخره سنموت ما
الفائده منها وايضا هناك يعني نقطه مهمه
يجب ان نوضحها هو يعرفها الدفاع المدني
وحتى يعني الاجهزه المتخصصه بالبحث
والانقاذ في مناطق النظام يعني كل
المساعدات التي وصلت او التي وعدت دول
بايصالها لا تتضمن فرق انقاذ لا تتضمن
اجهزه بحث يعني حراريه متطوره لا تتضمن
اليات الثقيله هذا هو المطلوب في هذه
المرحله اكثر من المساعدات الغذائيه وايضا
المساعدات الطبيه عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق
بكيفيه مساعده هؤلاء الناس يعني اذا كان
المنظمات الدوليه غير قادره للوصول هل في
جمعيات محليه تعمل على الارض قادره على
الحصول على الاموال وبالتالي قادره على
توفير احتياجات الناس وبالتالي يمكن لمن
هم خارج تلك المناطق مساعدتهم
نعم يعني يعني شاهدنا خلال اليومين
الماضيين يعني حملات تبرعات عينيه حملات
تبرعات يعني لجمع المساعدات الانسانيه
يعني اقصد الاكل والشراب وايضا يعني
الحليب للاطفال من بلدات ومدن اقل تضررا
تم يعني تجهيزها ونقلها الى البلدات
الاكثر
ضرورا اما يعني المنظمات
المحليه الصغيره او تلك التي تعمل كشراكه
بين مع المنظمات الكبيره استنفذت
مخزوناتها الموجوده داخل البلد انه اغلب
هذه المنظمات سواء كانت محليه او تعمل
كشراكه مع المعلومه من المتحده تعتمد في
تمويلها وايضا في يعني حملاتها الاغاثيه
على ما يصل من من تركيا من كافه اشكال
المعونات وبالتالي كل شيء كان موجود داخل
يعني ارياف حلب لا تسبب 5% من الاحتياجات
الحقيقيه التي خلفتها هذه
الكارثه نحن نتحدث عن يعني معابر لم تكن
مفعله ولم تفعل حتى الان من الطرف التركي
يعني معابر مع طرف الاكراد هناك خلاف يعني
حتى الشحنه التي ارسلها الاكراد لا تزال
عالقه في معمر ام جلود ولم يسمح لها
بالدخول ولو انها مساعدات انسانيه ايضا
المعابر يعني على الكروس لاين مع النظام
المعابر غير شرعيه طبعا ايضا لم يتقل منها
اي مساعدات من الدول العشره التي ارسلت
مساعدات ووصلت الى دمشق وحلب فبالتالي نحن
نتحدث عن نوع من الحصار بسبب الخلافات
السياسيه بسبب التعقيدات الروتينيه حاله
دون وصول هذه المساعدات حتى الان الى
المنكوبين في شمال غرب البلاد من القامش
لمراسل العربيه جمعه كاش شكرا جزيلا لك
الساعه 4:12 دقيقه بلشت الهزه يا دوب
نزلنا من البنايه وصارت الحياطين تهدم
علينا ويا دوب نفذنا بسابع والناس دروب
براسها بجسمها ونزلنا جوا على البستان
تمينا من الساعه اربعه
للوجه للصبح الساعه تسعه واحنا تحت المطر
وحاليا جيني على المخيم
وادينا الليله عند جيراننا بالخيام
بالخيام وغطسنا بالوحل للركب غطسنا يعني
ذبحنا البرد انا والله طالعوني من جوه
الانقاذ
فيقتني عيلتي البنايه دعت تهز شلت الويلات
راحت برا شي الحيطان كلها اتفشتني رجعتني
على
الغرفه عائلتي نزلت على الدرج هبط عليها
بيت الدرج
واولادي اثنيناتهم
نحن باركين في البيت نايم ما حسيت الا
الارض صارت دقيت بالاولاد وصارنا نرقد عند
الي رقدنا صارت رج الارض في زياده وطلعنا
والله يعني لله الامر التدبير طلعنا عراه
يعني والله سترنا اي والله بغيمت
صغيره
تنجح بانقاذ حساب كان قد علق تحت الانقاظ
هنا في مدينه حارم منذ اكثر من مضيء
ثلاثين ساعه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا ننتقل مباشره الى وزير النقل
التركي وهذه الكلمه والمؤتمر الصحفي لا
توجد اي مشاكل في الطرق الواصله الى
هذا المن
كوبه فقط مشكله بطلب المواطنين ان يدخلوا
الى هذه
الاماكن بسيارتهم الخاصه وهذا ما يتسبب
بازدحام
كثير في هذه المدن في الطرق الواصله الى
هذه المدن لذلك نرجو من المواطنين الا
يتوافدوا الى هذه المدن بسيارتهم الخاصه
قدر المستطاع بامكانهم ان يصلوا جريا على
الاقدام ولكن نرجو ان لا يتوفدوا الى هذه
المدن بسيارتهم الخاصه ربما
يستطيعون
بالحافلات الكبيره او عبر الخطوط الطيران
وما شابه ولكن نرجو الا يتوفدوا بسيراتهم
الخاصه ويتسببوا هنا بازدحام في السير
اثناء الدخول الى هذه نحن لن نغادر هذه
المدن قبل الانتهاء من عمليه البحث
والانقاذ المطارات تعمل بشكل كثيف وبشكل
سليم مطار هاتاي فقط هو الذي خارج يعتبر
خارج عن الخدمه بسبب
انهيار الذي حصل به وبسبب بعض الاضرار
الذي اصاب الطرق الواصله الى المطار ايضا
لذلك هناك اعمال كثيفه نراها فقط نحتاج
تامين
ربما طريقه تقديم هذه المساعدات طبعا
تضامن الشعب هو مصدر اما بالنسبه الينا
وحماس بالنسبه الينا لكن نرجو الا تكون
هناك استخدام للسيارات الخاصه كما ذكرنا
طبعا القطارات ايضا
قمنا بتاهلها بحيث تستضيف اكبر عدد ممكن
من العجينه من هذه الزلازل هم الان
يتواجدون في في مدينه هاتاي وما حولها
يتواجدون بشكل ثابت
افتتحناها وايضا شغلنا التدفئه فيها لكي
تؤوي اكبر عدد ممكن من المواطنين هناك
وايضا طبعا لدينا مخيبات تعمل على استضافه
وايواء اكبر عدد ممكن من
المواطن نحن نواجه احد اكبر كوارث هذا
العالم نقوم بالتدخلات اللازمه وعمليات
الانقاذ وتقديم المساعدات في رقع
الجغرافيه
واسعه وبالتالي نحتاج الى الدعم النفسي من
الجميع سنستمر باعمالنا كما ذكرت قبل قليل
سنستمر بجهودنا
قدر المستطاع ولكن نحاول ايضا
ظل كل هذه التحديات ان ننسق عمليه تقديم
المساعدات عدد كبير من المؤسسات
وطبعا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه الكلمه
نوافيكم باهم ورد فيها في سياق النشره
ولكن نكمل حول تبعات الزلزال في تركيا
وتصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
الذي اكد فيها ان المؤسسات الحكوميه
والوزارات ستعمل على اعاده اعمار المناطق
المنكوبه خلال عام وان الدوله ستقدم مبالغ
نقديه للاسر المتضرره طبعا لتخفيف العبء
المالي اردوغان ايضا اضاف انه سيتم محاسبه
كل من يحاول استغلال الكارثه للحصول على
مكاسب سياسيه دعونا نتابع
نحن في المؤسسات الحكوميه والوزارات نبذل
اقصى الجهود للمساعده والمشاركه في عمليه
البحث والانقاذ وهناك عدد كبير من
الموظفين الحكوميين هنا وكما ذكرنا سابقا
الهدف الاساسي هو اعاده اعمار المدينه في
اقصر وقت ممكن اي خلال عام تقريبا سيتم
اكمال اعاده بناء المباني السكنيه
والمدينه باكملها اما في هذه المرحله سيتم
تقديم عشره الاف ليره تركيه كمساعده نقديه
لكل اسره في المدن العشر المنكوبه وهذه
المبالغ ستساهم فقط في تخفيف العبء المالي
لكن مع الاسف نرى في هذه الاثناء محاولات
لاستغلال هذه الازمه لمصالح سياسيه لكن
نحن لن نسمح لهذه الاستغلالات وسنحاسبك كل
من يفعلها
[موسيقى]
مزيد معنا من هاتاي مفاده العربيه عمار
الهندي وايضا من اضنه زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه اهلا بكم ما زيدان انقلنا المشهد
من عندك
نعم ميسون قبل ان اكون معكم على الهواء
مباشره التقيت باحد عمال الانقاذ احد
المتطوعين الذي ينتمي او هو عضو في هيئه
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد اخف منهم
معلومات كثيره وكانت مهمه حقيقه عن السير
عمليات الانقاذ في هذا
الموقع اولا طبعا اخبرني بانه صباح هذا
اليوم انفجر هذا اليوم تم اخراج شخص كان
على قيد الحياه من تحت الركام
عفوا
تم اخراجه فجر هذا اليوم مع الاسف لم
نتمكن او لم نكون موجودين هنا لنقل هذا
الخبر السار وتلك الصوره التي كانت هنا في
هذا الموقع
عفوا مره ثانيه فجر هذا اليوم اذا تم
اخراج شخص كان على قيد الحياه في هذا
الموقع اكد لي ايضا انهم
خليني اعطيك وقت زيدان اذا مش مرتاح ربما
من الغبار في تلك المنطقه اعطيك مشي الحال
اكيد
ان شاء الله
اخبرني ايضا انهم هناك يعني التفاؤل كبير
جدا جدا بوجود اشخاص ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه تحت هذا المبنى حيث ان قبل قليل
اتى فريق متخصص معه كاميرات مراقبه حراريه
تم فحص الموقع هناك ثلاث نقاط في هذا
الموقع يقومون بالحفر في داخلها ويقومون
ايضا
طبعا باشراف فريق متخصص ايضا فريق الذي
الفريق الكلاب المدربه الذي وصل الى هذا
الموقع وهو متواجد في هذا الموقع اكد لنا
المشرف على الكلاب المدربه ان الكلاب
المدربه كانت تعطي اشارات بوجود اشخاص ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه هذه يعني يعني هذا
هو احت لكن احتمال كبير بان يكونوا ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه وما عزز هذه الفرص
هو نجاه شخص كما ذكرنا او انتشار شخص كان
بقي على قيد الحياه لليوم الرابع منذ حدوث
هذا الزلزال
مدى سهوله في ظل انه تركيا لديها الاليات
على الاقل وربما عدد كبير من العاملين مدى
سهوله الوصول الى هؤلاء
حقيقه ميسون رغم كل الامكانيات والاليات
الموجوده لكن الموضوع الوصول الى العالقين
تحت الانقاض وخصوصا اذا كان مثل هذا
البناء 14 طابقا يعني نحن يوم امس كان
العمل عند الطابق السابع وعندما ازالوا
بعض اركان قالوا ان هذا ركام هو من الطابق
السابع من خلال بعض المحتويات او التي
كانت بعض الاثاثات التي كانت مكسره وتعرف
عليها اصحاب بعض المنازل او الذين كانوا
موجودين هنا فتبين انها في الطابق السابع
يعني الموضوع ليس بهذه السهوله خصوصا
عندما يكون هناك شكوك ان هناك اشخاص ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه يتم العمل بهدوء رغم
كل هذه الاليات التي نشاهدها لكن في نقاط
معينه وهي النقاط الاساسيه التي يتم الحفر
همم عندها الحفر يكون باليات بسيطه جدا
منعا او خوفا من هبوط بعض الركام فوق
الاشخاص الذين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه
نقطه اخرى اخبرني بها المتطوع ميسون ان
معظم الاشخاص سواء كانوا الجثث او الناجين
الذين استطاعوا انتشارهم من هذا المبنى
كانوا
في الدرج يعني اثناء نزولهم من السلالم
بعد وقوع الزلزال انهار البناء وتقريبا
معظم الجثث الذين كانوا التي اخرجوها او
حتى الناجين كانوا عالقين بين السلالم في
الطواب في طوابق هذا البناء عندما انهار
هذا البناء لحظه حدوث الزلزال طبعا مع
الاسف اخبرني انهم وجدوا بعض اجزاء متفرقه
لضحايا مثلا يد مقطوعه او قدم مقطوعه
جدا على الجميع
او خاصه على هؤلاء الذين يحاولون انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه من هاتاي عمار انقل لنا
المشهد من عندك
اهلا ميسون سلاماتنا العزيز زيدان نعم
ميسون نحن نتابع من قصه الى اخرى ولكن نقف
على هذه البنايه حكايتها يعني حكايه
بصراحه اطلب من الزميل المصور ان يقترب
معي هذه البنايه لا تزال هنالك عشره
عائلات تحت الانقاض لم يتم الوصول اليها
بعد ميسون اليوم صباحا اخرجوا تسع اشخاص
احدهم كان على قيد الحياه والان تبقى عشره
عائلات كانت هذه البنايه كانت مكونه من
ثمان طبقات
وفي داخل هذه البنايه ايضا تسكن تسكن
عائلات سوريه وانا ساتحدث الان ان سمحت لي
ميسون مع احد الاشخاص الذي ينتظر الكشف عن
مصير اقربائه تحت هذه البنايه تحياتي لك
بس لو ننظر الى الكاميرا من فضلك اتعرف
عليك عبد مين لك انت تحت البنايه
الاثنين كامله
عددهم
تقريبا من الاشخاص وعيله خمس اشخاص لحد
الان ما عنا اي خبر عنهم والناس بيقولوا
اخذوها على المشفى وناس بيقولوا كذا بس
لحد الان تحت الانقاذه لا وحاولنا نسرح
عليهم من امامهم الخلف ومن كل الجهات انت
حاولت تدخل تحكيهم
جيت من غيره من الساعه سته الصبح الى الان
احاول لم اسمع اي صوت طب متى كان اخر
تواصل معهم اي شيء يعني اي شيء بتعرفوه
متى كم عدد المتواجدين كم عدد اللي كانوا
بره لما صار اثناء الزلزال كما تشاهد يعني
قطع صوته من الاسماء الزندال تحدثت
للمنقذيين لفرق الانقاذ ايش حكوا لك ايش
ايش قالوا لي انه اليوم استخرجوا شخص على
قيد الحياه على قدامي اخرج شخص
ضحايا طالعوها من فوق وفي شخص
للاسف
ويعني الوضع كتير كتير ماساوي الضحايا ما
تطلع مثل ما بتطلع شقف يعني اليوم ساعات
اخواننا الاتراك بالجيش الى الطياره يعني
متى يصلوا الى المكان اللي فيه شقق اي
طابق هم كانوا تحدثنا مع الدفاع المدني ان
شاء الله يعني يتموا للصباح لحتى ينهو
هيدي المكان لانه اكثر
عائله عم تشتكي عم تنتظر مثل ما انا بنتظر
وبتمنى انه الدفاع المدني يضم يستمر لانه
عم بيصير في بعض التاثيرات انه يضلوا من
وقت ربما بسبب انه كثره المواقع
والانهيارات يعني لانه الفرق نعم بس ولكن
انه هون 28 بيت يعني مو انه بيت بيتين
يعني انا سالت احد المنقذين يتحدث العربيه
واكد لي انه في عشر عائلات لا تزال تحت
الانقاض ان شاء الله نتمنى يعني ان يكونوا
سالمين ويعني تلقاهم سالمين بحول الله
ميسون نحن نتابع هذه القصه في الواقع
ولكني سالتف ايضا بالكاميرا الى الجهه
المقابله لاسرد لك قصه اخرى نتابعها ولكن
من بعيد لانها يعني هنالك حساسيه وخوف من
البنايه التي
تجاهدينها الان عبر الكاميرا هذه البنايه
ميسون لم تنهار ولكنها سقطت في الاسفل
بعمق التسويه وهنالك اشخاص ثلاث شباب
سوريين محاصرين داخل تسويه هذه البنايه
كان احد اقربائهم اتصل معهم واجاب احد
الاشخاص تحت الانقاض على الهاتف واكد انه
على قيد الحياه وهذا كان امس الاتصال بعد
ذلك الهاتف يرن ولا يجيبوا وجاء فريق
متخصص اليوم ولديه اجهزه متطوره واكد ان
هنالك حياه لاشخاص تحت الانقاض ويعني من
خلال الاجهزه تبين ان هنالك من هو على قيد
الحياه وبالتالي عمليات حساسه جدا ان كانت
زميل يستطيع الدخول اكثر في الكاميرا الى
هناك هم يقول اي اصعب يعني بالنسبه لرجال
الانقاذ ان يحاولوا ان يشيلوا الركام
ليجدوا من تحته او ببنايه مثل هذه او هذا
المبنى ان يحاول الوصول الى القاع وخاصه
انه ممكن فكره انهيار المبنى نفسه تكون
قائمه صحيح
بالتاكيد بالضبط يعني انا اكثر عمليه
انقاذ اراها حساسه هذه العمليه رغم ان
البنايه غير منهاره لانهم حذروا احنا كنا
اقتربنا للتصوير هناك وكان تحذير حازم جدا
انه لا لن لن يقف هناك سوى فرق الانقاذ
لانه في بعض رجال الانقاذ دخلوا بالفعل
على عمق امتار في تلك البنايه الان هم تحت
يحاولوا ان يدخلوا ويصلوا الى هؤلاء
الاشخاص العالقين وتحدثت من قبل بانه قصه
هؤلاء الشباب احدهم جاء من اسطنبول الى
هذه المدينه ليله الزلزال ميسون يعني
تمهيدا لكتب كتابه للزواج ولكنه للاسف
يعني هذا كان ما حدث معه انه تحت الانقاذ
المبنى متصدع اصلا
بدي اسال سؤال فيما يتعلق
بفرق الانقاذ لانه تحدثنا عن ارقام كبيره
خاصه في تركيا ومنهم من تطوع الى اي حد
هذه الفرق فعلا لديها الكفاءه كامله
والتجربه والمهاره في التعاطي مع مثل هذه
الازمات
اولا يعني طبعا هم على مستوى عالي جدا من
الكفاءه وهذا واضح
زائد انه هنالك فرق انقاذ ليست فقط تركيا
يعني فريق الانقاذ الذي كشف بالجهاز
الحراري عن وجود احياء او وجود يعني حياه
تحت هذا المبنى كان فريق اردني مثلا
وهنالك فريق اخر من جنسيه غير تركيا تعمل
في نفس الموقع الان في يعني وهم الذين
طلبوا بطانيات قبل تقريبا نصف ساعه من
الان وبالتالي هنالك يعني متطوعين كثر
سواء من داخل تركيا او من خارج تركيا
يعملون بطاقه كبيره جدا بدقه كبيره جدا
ولكن ميسون السؤال الاهم انه لماذا هنالك
بعض البنايات مثلا التي لم تبدا حتى هذه
اللحظه فيها العمليات بشكل كبير اعطيك
مثالا سالتفت ايضا قليلا على بنايه اخرى
شاهدي في هذه البنايه ميسون في الكاميرا
ان كانت تظهر هذه البنايه مدمره بالكامل
وفيها عائلات كثيره حتى اللحظه تخيلي نحن
في اليوم الرابع العمليات بدات فيها قبل
ساعه من الان يعني هم الان يقوموا
يعني بفحص المبنى قبل البدء بعمليات
الانقاذ هذا شو سببه سببه كثره المواقع
المنهاره تخيلي انا التفت يعني سنتيمتر
بالكاميرا فتجدي مبنى منهار هنا ومبنى
منهار هنا ومبنى منهار هنا السؤال الكبير
ما هي الاولويه واين تكمن الاولويه شعور
بالذنب بالنهايه اذا ما اكتشفوا ان هناك
عائلات ربما كان من الممكن انقاذها اسمح
لي ان انتقل الى زيدان لينقل ايضا لنا
الصوره من عنده زيدان
نعم ميسون انا سالتي عمار سؤال قبل قليل
نفس السؤال سالته الى المتطوع الذي اجرينا
مقابله معه لقناه العربيه قبل قليل هو من
اين جاء وكيف بدا العمل هنا في هذا الموقع
المدمر اخبرني انه هو بالاساس هو من ولايه
اضنه لكنه كان يعيش في اسطنبول وكان لحظ
يعني يوم الزلزال كان في زياره لعائلته
هنا في اضنه وعند حدوث الزلزال
التحق فورا بفرق المتطوعين كونه عضو
بمنظمه افاد او هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه واخبرني ان جميع العاملين في هذه
المنظمه على الاقل على الاقل يتلقون
تدريبات لمده عامين قبل ان يصبحوا ضمن
طواقب الانقاذ لذلك كما تحدث الزميل عمار
لديهم من الخبره والكفاءه الكثير لكن حجم
الكارثه كبير جدا حقيقه رغم ان الارقام
الرسميه تؤكد انه
حوالي 24 الف من عمال الانقاذ لكن على ما
يبدو ان حجم الدمار يتطلب اكبر من هذا
العدد بكثير علما ان من بين ال 24 الف
حوالي خمسه الاف من الاجانب غير الاتراك
وهذا يعني ايضا مؤشر اضافي على ان هذا
الزلزال يحتاج الى اضعاف هذا الاعداد وكما
تحدث الزميل عمار هناك ابنيه حتى الان لم
يتم الوصول اليها او وصلوا اليها قبل
ساعات او يوم امس اي بعد مرور اكثر من 48
ساعه لحدوث الزلزال وهذا مرده طبعا الى
الدمار الكبير خصوصا في ولايه حيث يتواجد
الزميل عمار او في ولايه كهرمان مرعش هل
تم الاعلان عن اي منطقه بانه تم الانتهاء
من عمليه او محاولات الانقاذ وحتى
الانتشال او لا
نعم ولايه كلس جنوب غازي عنتاب هذه
الولايه المحاذيه تماما للحدود السوريه
والتي يوجد فيها معبر باب السلامه او تطل
على معبر باب السلامه في قباله مدينه
اعزاز هذه الولايه تم الاعلان قبل يومين
عن انتهاء عمليات البحث
والانقاذ وتم تقريبا سحب كل الجثث العالقه
الدمار لم يكن كبيرا في تلك الولايه كانت
بعيده نوعا ما عن مركز الزلزال في
كهرمان مرعش كان معنا زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه من اضنه شكرا جزيلا لك ومنها
الطاي مفرد العربيه عمار الهندي شكرا
جزيلا لك ولضيوفك
جوله حصريه قامت بها كاميرا العربيه في
مدينه كهرمان مرعش اكثر المناطق المتضرره
جراء الزلزال في تركيا تفاصيل مع الزميل
غسان ابو لوز
نحن الان في مدينه كهرمان مرعش وهي اكثر
المدن تضررا في البلاد نتيجه الزلزال تعد
مدينه منكوبه كما وصفتها السلطات نقف الان
عند احد المباني المنهاره هذا المبنى من
تسع طوابق الان يقولون بان هناك خمسه
اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض في احد مواقف
السيارات احد الاشخاص يقول بانه تلقى
الرساله من
العالقين في
اسفل هذه الانقاض تواصل عمليات
الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه مستمره
وتم يتم استخدام الان الكلاب
يعني اجهزه حديثه اجهزه استشعار حديثه
ربما لعل وعسى يتمكنون من الوصول الى
الاشخاص العالقين تحت هذه الانقاض هذا
يعني المشهد الذي تشاهدونه الان هو جزء من
كارثه كبرى ضربت البلاد
تشاهدون الان هذا المبنى ايضا ايل الى
السقوط قبل قليل فرق الانقاذ حذرت من هذا
المبنى وقالت بان هناك اصوات تصدر من هذا
المبنى وربما يعني يكون هناك تداعيات
سلبيه في حال وجود اهتزازات ارضيه عموما
الوضع في كهرمان مرعش سيء جدا وعمليات
الانقاذ ما زالت متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه
غساله العربيه كهرمان مرعش
[موسيقى]
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا لم يفرق
طبعا بين الكبار والاطفال الكارثه حصدت
مئات الارواح من الاطفال ربما العدد
النهائي غير معلوم لانه تبعات الماساه لم
تنتهي بعد على كل حول تداعيات هذه الازمه
تحديدا على الاطفال ينضم الينا من عمان
عمار عمار وهو المسؤول الاقليمي
لليونيسيفي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا اهلا بك استاذ عمار اسمح لي ان
ابدا بقراءه لوضعكم على الارض اين تنتشرون
ان كان في الجانب التركي او في الجانب
السوري وطبيعه عملكم الان
اللحظه لا يوجد ارقام تتعلق بالاطفال
وحدهم باسل اكيد انه الاصابات تتجاوز
الالاف بين بين للاسف يعني ضحايا من
الاطفال وكذلك من الجرحى وكمان عدد كتير
كتير من النازحين من الاطفال الذين نزحوا
مع عائلتهم هربا من الزلزال خوفا من
الزلزال ممكن يكون بيوتن مهدمه اخاف من
الهزات الارتداديه فافطرش الشوارع وافترش
بعض
المدارس كذلك تحت الجسور في الطرقات
العامه في الحدائق العامه في وضع
هناك كلمه مضطره ان انتقل اليها واعود
اليك ربما
شكرا
الزلزال الذي تسبب بازمه انسانيه ما يزال
ياخذ مستويات اسوا
والامم متحده قد فعلت ما بوسعها لتكون على
حجم الاستجابه فنحن نقوم بنشر خبراء
لتقييم الاضرار ونعمل على التنسيق مع فرق
الاغاثه وتامين المواد الطبيه وبعض المواد
الاخرى الموقده للحياه واننا ملتزمون بفعل
المزيد ولهذا السبب فانني كنت قد طلبت من
وكيل لغات الانسانيه السيد قرفه ليسافر
الى المناطق المتضرره باسرع ما يمكن وهو
قد وصل الى تركيا وسوف يزور غازه عنتاب
حلب ودمشق للوقوف على الاحتياجات ومعرفه
كيف لنا ان نقوم بزياده دعمنا
من اجل تقديم هذه المساعدات اننا بحاجه
الى امرتين الى امرين اولا قدره الوصول
فالناس يموتون وهذا هو الوقت
لاستكشاف وكافه السبل الممكنه التي يمكن
من خلالها بلوغ كافه المناطق اننا بحاجه
لانقاذ ارواح البشر ثانيا المصادر ان
صندوق الاعانات
بحاجه الى دعم على الحدود السوريه
والخيارات الافضل هي من خلال شركاء الامم
المتحده الذين لابد لهم ان يهبوا لمساعده
الناس قد تم تحرير 25 مليون دولار لهذا
صندوق كبدايه لكن في مطلع الاسبوع القادم
سوف نقوم باطلاق مناشده للدول الماني حرب
سوف تخصص لهؤلاء الذين تضرروا في سوريا
كما قلت لكم فان الامم المتحده بالعمل مع
منظمات غير الحكوميه تعمل على الاستجابه
في سوريا وتقوم بتقييم المتطلبات الاوليه
للاشهر الثلاثه القادمه هذه المصادر
والمعرسه سوف تستخدم من قبل المنظمات
الانسانيه من اجل
الحاجات الاساسيه مثل الماوى والتدفئه
وغيرها من
المتطلبه الرئيسيه كذلك ايضا سوف نقوم
بدعم
المتطلبات في تركيا باسرع ما يمكن في وجه
هذه الكارثه غير المسبوقه فانني اهيب
بالاسره الدولي ان تظهر لتركيا وسوريا
نفسي نوع الدعم الذي كانوا قدموه في
مساعده وحمايه ملايين اللاجئين
والنازحين في اظهار كبير للتضامن الان هو
وقت اظهار التضامن مع الشعبين السوري
والتركي
الامين العام شكرا جزيلا
لدي سؤالا السؤال الاول هل تعتقدون انه
يجب ان يكون هناك المزيد من
المعابر الحدوديه التي يجب فتحها فضلا عن
باب الهوى
ثانيا لابد لمجلس الامن ان يصدر بيانا
حوله هذه الكارثه او ان يناقش الامر هل
لديكم اي تعليق بهذا الشان هذه لحظات وحده
وليست اللحظات لتسييس الامر او للفرقه لكن
من الواضح اننا بحاجه الى دعم كبير لدى
فانني سوف اكون سعيدا اذا ما كان مجلس
الامن سوف يتوصل الى اصدار بيانا او قرار
لفتح المزيد من المعابر الحدوديه كما اننا
بحاجه لزياده قدراتنا لتقديم العمليات عبر
الخطوط في ادلب
وصولا الى دمشق
الحكومه السوريه
سعاده الامين العام تقول بان كافه
المساعدات يجب ان تنطلق
بدءا من دمشق وعبر الخطوط هل هذا كافن
المساعدات عبر الخطوط تعد مهمه لكن
الكارثه هي اكبر باننا لدرجه اننا بحاجه
للمساعدات عبر الحدود وعبر الخطوط وهذه
المسائل يجب ان لا تسيس هذه لحظات يجب لنا
ان نعمل سويه من اجل دعم المتضررين وكما
قلت لكم ان الناس كانوا قد اظهروا حسا من
الكرامه
[موسيقى]
والضيافه التي لا تضاعها عندما استقبل
عددا كبيرا من اللاجئين من سوريا وتركيا
والعراق
ما الذي ترونه انه حجر العثر
اذا مشاهدينا صندوق من 25 مليون دولار
لمساعده
المتضررين من هذا الزلزال وايضا حديث عن
مناشده قادمه للدول المانحه اعود الى ضيفي
مش عارفه رح ارجع
طيب لا اعلم ان كان ضيفه سيد عمار عمار
المسؤول الاقليمي لليونيسف لا زال معي او
لا
كنا نتحدث عن العمل على الارض بالنسبه
لليونيسف ذكرت انه ليس هناك من عدد
للاطفال
ان كان القتلى او الضحايا بصوره عامه ولكن
هناك الالاف كما تعتقدون لديكم تواجد على
الارض في كامل الاراضي السوريه طبيعه
الدعم الذي تقدمونه الان في هذا الوضع
شكرا في المقام الاول التركيز على موضوع
المياه الصالح هذا للشرب بالاضافه الى ذلك
التغذيه وحمايه الاطفال فيما يتعلق طبعا
خاصه بموضوع المياه الصالحه للشرب بالايام
القليله ما بعد الزلزال هذه ايام تعتبر
اساسيه لحتى نمنع ظهور الامراض تعرفي انه
بسوريا كانت موجوده الكره من سبتمبر السنه
الماضيه وما زال مستمر وما زال موجود
والخوف خلال الزلزال انه لما يكون في
تدمير او شبكات المياه
الصرف الصحي مع شبكات المياه الشرب ممكن
تختلط مع بعض
وبالتالي ممكن تسبب امراض فبالتالي تعمل
اليونيسف الان بشكل مباشر على تقييمه على
الاضرار التي لحقت في شبكات المياه للعمل
على اصلاحها وكذلك كاجراء مؤقت تقوم
بتوفير المياه الصالحه للشرب لحتى ما يكون
في تفاقم للاوبئه والامراض المرتبطه بشرب
المياه الملوثه فهذا في المقام الاول
ذكرت التغذيه هل لديكم كافه ما تحتاجونه
لتقديم الغذاء غوتيرس كان يتحدث عن ان اول
قافله مساعدات دخلت الى الشمال السوري قبل
ساعات هل لديكم من قافلات قد دخلت او في
تنسيق نحن طبعا
المواد
الاغاثيه التي كانت موجوده لديها داخل
البلد في الاستجابه للحالات الطارئه
غير كافيه لانه لانه هيدي كانت موجهه اصلا
الاشخاص الذين هم بحاجه اليها يعني نحن
بنعرف مليونين شخص بحاجه لمساعدات اكثر
تقريبا اكثر من سبعه مليون طفل وهذول
هؤلاء الاشخاص والاطفال ما زالوا بحاجه
الى هذه المساعدات بالاضافه الى
الاحتياجات الكبيره التي خلفها الزلزال
فالي
نطاق تعطيكم مع الاطفال لو سمحت وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بهؤلاء الذين فقدوا كل
عائلاتهم باختصار باختصار عندنا برامج
فيما يتعلق للاطفال هي حمايه الطفل
بالنسبه للاطفال الذين تفرقوا انا واائلهم
المقام الاول اعاده لم شملهم وايضا
على قيد الحياه المسؤول الاقليمي لليونيسف
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا من
عمان عمار عمار شكرا جزيلا لك معي من
بروكس
لجنه الدفاع والخارجيه في البرلمان
البلجيكي اهلا بك سيد اندريه خبرنا عن
طريقه
تعطيكم مع هذه الكارثه الانسانيه ودوركم
ان كان هناك على الارض الان
ما يتبادر الى الذهن عندما يضرب زلزال من
هذا القبيل هو اننا نفكر بالضحايا وكذلك
حشد الجهود وبسرعه من اجل التعبير التضامن
وهذا التضامن هنا ينبغي تعبير عنها بشان
شعبه تركي وكذلك الشعب السوري من الاهميه
بما كان ايضا ناخذ في الحسبان انه في ظروف
من هذا القبيله تضامن ليس لديه حدود وهذا
هو السبب الذي جعل رد الفرده الفعل فوريه
وهذا يذكرني بوضع عندما كنت وزيرا للدفاع
عشت ذلك عام
1999 اثناء الزلزال الذي ضرب التركيه
في ذلك الوقت قررنا مع وزير الخارجيه هو
الان السيد ميساء الرئيس المجلس الاوروبي
والحكومه قررنا انشاء
بنيه او هيكل الاستجابه الفوريه وذلك من
خلال حشد جهود وزاره الدفاع وزاره
الداخليه ووزاره الصحه ووزاره الخارجيه من
اجل تبني موقف ومقاربه منسقه للاستجابه
لاحتياجات الدول المتضرره من الزلزال حتى
نتحرك باسرع ما يمكن لتلبيه الاحتياجات
ودون ان يقتصر ذلك على التعبير عن التضامن
دون ان يؤدي الى نتائج ملموسه لذلك فان
هذه
المقاربه اللي هي التي
تسامحت لنا باننا البلد الاوروبي الاول
الذي ارسل مستشفى ميداني الى تركيا
وهناك فرق طبيه ايضا وكذلك بطانيه تم
ارسالها في ظل تدني درجات الحراره الى
مستويات قياسيه وعلاوه على ذلك يجب ان
نحرص ان ضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا يمكن ان يحصلوا على
المساعده الاليه البلجيكيه لا يمكن لها ان
تتدخل في منطقه تشهد حرب ولكن يمكن من
الخارج ندعم المنظمات غير الحكوميه
والهياكل الاوروبيه للاستجابه ايضا
للنداءات التي اطلقتها السلطات السوريه
اذا بهذا المستوى نتحرك اليوم من خلال
عمليه تشمل الرد السعدي والمنسق وكذلك من
خلال الاعداد لمساعدات مستدامه لانه يجب
ان نكون متواجدين ايضا الى جانب هذه
الشعوب المتضرره
عندما تغادر وسائل الاعلام عندئذ يجب
علينا ان نكون متواجدين ويجب ان
نتجاوز الاوقات الرهينه للمساعده لان
المساعده المستدامه والملموسه مهمه
الدفاع والخارجيه في البرلمان البلجيكي
شكرا جزيلا لك وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه الخامسه شكرا للمتابعه والتغطيه
مستمره مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]